happy St Patrick's Day
hey look some ideas are so smart it's
hard to believe that no one ever thought
of them before this here is one of those
ideas if you've ever mowed the lawn or
thought it has to be a better and easier
way to do this guess what you were right
there is a better way to do it you can
just rent some Lambs to do it for you a
new company lets you hire lamb mowers
instead of lawn mowers Corey Suter is
the owner of lambmowers.com he's based
in Fairfax County and Corey joins us now
to explain and you have your labor force
behind you Corey how is it no one has
thought of this you've got to tell me
about your inspiration and the market
demand for lamb mowers
ah thanks so much will I don't want to
go out too much on a lamb here I didn't
know if you wanted me to Ram through
some bad cheap
I'm really honored to be on your show
we're glad to have you we're glad to
have you here on Tucker Carlson tonight
go ahead I want to hear this I have a
ton of questions about though your
Workforce there and their appetite
yeah well we are the only licensed and
insured landscaping company that also
gets invited to kids birthdays and
evening wine parties we also have a lot
of customers that just hire us to get
rid of the weeds and that's what makes
me so passionate about what I do I got
into landmillers.com because I care
about conserving Soil and Water
Resources for future generations and my
sheep do a wonderful job of putting
organic matter back in soil where it
belongs
I have a lot of happy customers it
brings people a lot of joy to have sheep
in their yard putting organic matter
back into the soil where it belongs is
is that mean I have to hire like a poop
pickup service after you mow my lawn
with the Lambs you fertilize as you as
you cut the lawn
so my sheep do provide some
biodegradable fertilizer pellets uh and
um yeah if you're putting the lawn
clippings back on the lawn that's what
our soil needs you know all of our soils
here in the U.S used to have over eight
percent organic matter and now we're
back down to only
um around half a percent a lot of our
farmland and that just means there's not
a lot of nutrients left in that soil to
feed us it fuels the Obesity epidemic in
the U.S to have soils that are depleted
of nutrients and organic matter yeah and
so I'm really passionate about uh soil
health and um you know doing land mowers
is one way I help educate people about
that I've actually read a lot about that
recently according to your point the
soil has lost a lot of its nutritional
value through industrial farming and
widespread use of chemical fertilizer
and as we point out you're giving back
and I'm going to tell my wife the same
thing when I don't pick up in the
backyard I'm giving back to the soil
right now but but Corey really quick the
names that's right lazy gardening is
great the names of the names of your
work force behind you can you introduce
me to a few of them
sure so right here in front of me I
think this is Oreo and then um okay yeah
you can't see that so do you see snowy
here the cutest little lamb yeah and
then right behind her is her mother uh
chocolate chip behind that's ice cream
I'm picking up
um it looks like oh okay yes uh my kids
helped name the sheep and uh I I see you
really have a lot of fun um
uh Corey we've got a little bit delay
that's why kids named a sheep monster
truck so that must have been we call
Monty for sure I hate I hate to to
enforce gender stereotypes but that must
have been one of your sons
um the the uh the Corey I'm I'm seeing
the before and after pictures of of your
Workforce there and what you've done in
the backyards of many overgrown
neighborhoods your your Lambs eating
through what no lawnmower weed eater can
make their way through so it's a
fascinating business it's an opening in
the market it's giving back as you point
out to the planet and uh we wish you and
marshmallow and Oreo and monster truck
all all the best uh in your business
lamb mowers thank you Corey oh
supporting a local small business I
really appreciate you having me on the
show will you bet hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else